philippe béchade bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
hier on le disait lors de son interview
du 14 juillet le président de la
république a annoncé une enveloppe de
100 milliards d'euros qui seront
consacrés à la relance industrielle
écologiques locales culturelles et
éducatives
alors toujours cette question comment
cette somme sera t-elle débloquer et
sera t elle suffisante selon vous alors
suffisante on l'espère la façon dont
elle sera débloquée bien emmanuel macron
semblent parier sur l'adoption du budget
de relance paneuropéen de 750 milliards
en fait ce sont purement et simplement
des subventions aux pays qui en ont le
plus besoin et emmanuel mâcon semble
penser que la france pourrait bénéficier
d'environ 40 % des 100 milliards qu'il
propose
autrement dit 40 milliards qui seraient
pris en président serait de 5 ans charge
par le budget européen resterait 60
milliards qui eux seraient financées sur
le long terme on peut presque parler
d'ailleurs quand on évoque ses
financements à long terme de dette
perpétuelle qui sont roulés indéfiniment
de façon à ne pas peser sur le budget et
monsieur macron a annoncé que ce plan ce
ne serait pas financée par les impôts ce
qui serait également un frein juge
justement par d'achat alors justement et
puis on peut aussi ajouter que cette
somme s'ajoute aux aux 460 milliards
déjà engagée depuis le début de
l'épidémie
cette augmentation d'impôts pour
compenser l'explosion des dépenses
publiques
elle n'aura pas lieu on peut croire le
chef de l'état le meccano financier
permet effectivement de transformer une
dette comme je le disais en quasi dette
perpétuel on peut l'étendre sur 15 ans
sur 20 ans jusqu'à la rendre
pratiquement indolore mais une dette à
terme doit toujours être remboursés
autrement dit on ne fait que repousser
ou mettre sur le dos des générations
futures les dettes qui ne seront pas
payés aujourd'hui mais en tout cas
psychologiquement c'est important que le
chef d'état ne place pas les français
dans la perspective de on a un ou deux
ans de bon et derrière il va falloir
payer la facture parce que
psychologiquement
tout le monde aurait un réflexe
d'epargne face à un risque d' impôts
donc le le seul à impôt qui va continuer
de peser semblerait-il ce seront donc
les taxes foncières sur les ménages les
plus aisés
autrement dit bon quelque chose qui
épargnera 95% de la population alors
vous parliez des générations futures
justement avec les 100 milliards d'euros
emmanuel macron veut des mesures fortes
pour la jeunesse comme des exonérations
de charges pour les jeunes diplômés ou
encore la mise en place entre autres un
deux trois cent mille contrats
d'insertion
c'est un bon levier selon vous pour
faire redémarrer la machine si je peux
me permettre c'est certainement un bon
levier le curseur a été placée à 1,6
smic
ce qui permet effectivement d'embaucher
des jeunes qualifiés donc des
non-qualifiés probablement au au smic ou
quatre cinquièmes de smic en fonction
des horaires des uns les autres et
jusqu'à 1,6 c'est à dire permettant
d'embaucher de jeunes de jeunes diplômés
donc une mesure certainement efficace et
qui le sera à partir du moment où on va
dire que la croissance économique aura
retrouvé une certaine traction
monsieur macron a déjà prévenu que
l'automne va être difficile qu'il
corresponde à une période où on verra le
chômage explose et c'est à l'automne
qu'on verra par exemple dans le secteur
hôtellerie restauration
ceux qui tentent de reprendre leur
activité et ceux qui jetteront l'épongé
clairement après la période automnale
on espère certainement un redémarrage
fin d'année début 2021 donc en se
préparant là aussi à ce que l'hôtel soit
soit mauvais compliqué avec des chiffres
du chômage certainement les pires qu'on
aura connu depuis les années 80 bah
finalement ce ménage la possibilité
d'avoir plutôt de bonnes surprises
si on anticipe le pire est que le pire
n'est jamais certain
autrement dit à l'automne on ne sera pas
effrayé par de mauvais chiffres s'ils
sont déjà attendus alors pour conclure
en quelques mots un autre dossier
brûlant à celui de la réforme des
retraites il est toujours sur la table
avec le bouleversement économique et
social auquel on est en train d'assister
est ce que la réforme des retraites
voulue par le gouvernement tient
toujours
alors il ya une volonté politique de
montrer qu'on ne veut pas changer de cap
monsieur macron a parlé de changer de
chemin mais pour toujours viser le même
cap bon on sait que cette retraite dès
cette réforme des retraites était très
très mal parti à l'automne 2010 9
elle a même dû être adoptée à coups de
49,3 un fameux 29 février où le
gouvernement avait le gouvernement
étaient réunis à priori pour prendre
d'été des mesures contre le coc vide et
on s'est retrouvé à 49,3 sur les
retraites
bon cette retraite cette réforme ne
passe pas bien sur toi un aspect qui est
quand même majeur c'est qu'on voulait le
gouvernement voulait plafonner
le prélèvement à hauteur de 14% du pib
quand on a un pib qui chute de 10%
qu'est ce qui se passe pour les
retraites si on adopte ce genre de
mécanisme
ça veut dire que les retraités vont se
retrouver pieds de 8 ou 9% de leurs
pensions dont il ya des choses à revoir
évidemment dans cette réforme est bon on
va dire que vu les circonstances c'est
clairement pas la priorité en tout cas
pas sous sa forme actuelle de prêt en
tout cas merci philippe béchade d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la bourse
au quotidien